[Music]
whoa this music cut out yeah
what is this Rudy giuliani's podcast
right what the hell what up everybody
[Applause]
that's right
that's right farther
I gotta tell you I'm close to drop right
that's true
you know we always talk about how well
these uh conservatives monetize with the
slot buckets and yeah yeah yeah
I don't know the new Trail picks uh gold
Iraqi dinar uh cryptocurrencies that
immediately are just a a rug pull so I'm
close to finally making my own product
you're gonna make your own slime I've
been thinking you know Alex Jones she's
got he's got everything I am close to
dropping my own hell yeah brother this
poisonable made by Ethan not yet
approved by the FDA but it will be
[Music]
right I'm not going to say what it is
but you guys tried it
yeah we did should I just say what it is
no I would wait I don't know
but I'm passionate about it this is
purely an even Endeavor man like this
man you're you're you're making you're
making a meme bucket it's almost no it's
not a slot bucket it's a real product
it's a passion project so you're crazy
is really clown comedian shut the [__]
up I'm being serious Jordan God Jordan's
coming after you
I'm just gonna I'll say I'm gonna say it
say it I'm making today I'm here to
announce that I am closing in on the
final formulation
here today at slotbucket.com
on a product I like to call movement
which is essentially
a rip-off of Metamucil what what I don't
even know what Metamucil is most people
under 60 don't
what is a Metamucil it's a powder you
take that helps again it's made of
[__] it's for like it's literally
for dude you should take less of that
actually I don't think anyone's ever
recommended that you should take less
whatever because I'm looking at it right
now no it tightens your [__] it's a
fiber it's a fiber supplement yeah yeah
you definitely should take less than
that I think so bro you literally what
do you mean [__] breaks for like 15
minutes
but for me it's I'm passionate about it
I'll tell you why
it's because psyllium husk like that has
been proven dude I'm [__] my pants
lower cholesterol to lower blood sugar
spikes to fill you up
yeah I mean it's fiber it's fiber it
makes sense I take fiber I take fiber
supplements or I used to take fiber
supplements
I I love fiber supplements I used to
take five percent I still do sometimes
when I when I get constipated no but I
eat a lot of greens okay I I eat a salad
pretty much every meal like with a
shitload of protein on it so it doesn't
really matter to me but I I still take
like smart sweets which are Fiber
Gummies
they're gummies but with a lot of fiber
in them gummies with fiber oh please you
should you should be
kissing my butthole because the amount
of ice [__] actually just shows it works
I got the golden butthole I mean I I I
have
I have a really I have a really good
shooting schedule
okay it's it's firm it's perfect like
every day it's it's the same every day
it's at the same time every day and
um
depending on how much depending on how
much I eat like if I overeat yeah if I
don't eat the same thing if I overeat
then like I'll I'll usually go to the
bathroom twice or maybe even sometimes
three times in the morning times like
three separately in the morning all in
the morning all in the morning and then
we're good to go
yeah my my BMS have never been uh SK I
could never get them on a schedule man
they're just chaos it's just chaos well
I think it's because your body's a
machine Ethan thank you and not just
like no I didn't mean like I didn't mean
like your body specifically I heard it
just I meant in general your body is a
machine and
so your input and your output are going
to be relatively stable for that reason
right like
if you eat crazy yeah if you if you eat
like different [__] all the time at
different times
uh and and you know you have big meals
small meals all that sort of stuff then
you're you're
you know your movement internally is
going to look like that
sure I did a terrible job of describing
that I know what you're saying but I'm
not hearing it
you know what I mean just not right I'm
not hearing it science is gay
that's true that's also true though
unless you're doing unless you're doing
like bro sides which is gym related okay
it's very straight listen we gotta kind
of cut to the chase here great to see
you son thanks for being here and our 20
kajillion dollar bunker great to be here
um today we're having a call in from the
great esteemed Professor Richard Wolff
yes oh you calling the wolf yeah yes
we're calling the wolf Dick Wolf
famously whose side projects Law and
Order series right which is really cool
I hope you guys have a bunch of Law and
Order questions it's actually all I put
in the dock I have so many questions
about Stabler and uh Munch yeah I'm
gonna be like why do you do so much
propaganda like if you're a Marxist okay
hold on guys Richard Belzer guys I got
to keep her on the rails because he's
calling in at 10 45. that's 15 minutes
and we only have him for an hour yeah so
we got 15 minutes here to
show some good [__] okay
I'm I I'd like to point out I'm very
excited to to hang with dick you hang to
hang dick
um
uh he is I mean he's he's very important
for a lot of uh the most annoying people
online that were like
I'm gonna graduate from looking at
socialism memes to like learn a little
bit about it um so like his lectures are
available on YouTube all over
but but all jokes aside I think he's
great he's a he's a very good
communicator of marxist awesome Concepts
so I I am excited to talk to him
actually I think it's a good idea to use
this 15 minutes here to intro him a
little bit so we don't have to waste
time well before we do that how about
you have my boy on yesterday oh yeah
right me and Bryce are dogs he's such a
nice guy right sweet guy I know I know
him look this this year or this past
year for me Bryce uh and and Mike uh as
well Big Mike yeah Mike's two people
that I like would have never thought I
would ever like talk to never thought I
would be friends with never thought like
thought they were douchebags you know
from afar judge the book by its cover
and I was wrong you know Bryce is a he's
an interesting guy there's a lot Charlie
Martin too actually yeah well Brad
Bradley's a sweetheart I had a feeling
he would you know he comes off as a
sweetie pie but Bryce to me he's a young
man but he's been through a lot he grew
up without a father he was bullied in
high school like severely uh he told me
he used to eat his lunch in a stall by
himself apparently a few of these losers
also did that I didn't know that was a
thing about me I have friends
that's crazy that's a that's a thing
that I mean guys will in Turkey so I
don't know he said no it shocked me too
I never heard of it he said he used to
go into every day during lunch and eat
in the stall by himself I look I wasn't
exactly popping in high school like I
don't know how to describe my
experiences in high school through the
lens of an American High School but uh I
I'll just say it like this I drew so
much that's all I did every class I
would just sit there and draw do you
ever draw titties and jerk off to them
yes I have done I've never done that but
I've heard from friends who did that
okay listen first of all porn is banned
porn is banned in Turkey what do you
want me to do did you ever did you ever
draw one that was like really good so
you saved it for later
or did you start news no because I was
always really like I would draw I'm so I
would used to be so good at drawing like
[__] big Burly dudes from video games
and like animes and [__] right so
whenever I tried to draw women like the
pers the perspective was off okay like
they were they were more titty than than
person right right so it's kind of anime
yeah and I just I I kind of failed at it
a little bit
um
but I guess I wasn't horny enough to
like get better at it yeah
well anyway bright and then Bryce did
this really incredible thing for me
um
uh Ryan Kavanaugh as bestie Brad the
bull the guy who rails his ex-wife now
ex-wife
um
so much about this dude he called in bro
and he the minute he saw my face he was
like [__] me bro like he was so upset
and Ryan Kavanaugh also called in during
the show he answered it I heard his
voice and he's like yo I'm on the show
I'm live right now I can't talk he's
like okay call me back but that would
all happen live so your besties with him
and you're stealing him from from Ryan
that's what I think Ryan's going to
perceive it that way yeah I mean I like
I like Bryce I think he's nice he's a
nice kid yeah he's awesome it was it was
a good time
yeah and so um
before so as we're on the heels of uh
the heels
the precipice of the wolf call here's
the video that I saw on Tick Tock that
made me wonder who was this guy this is
one of uh because I'm so [__] tired
of seeing Jordan Peter's
pseudo-intellectualism and it's hard
like
he keeps going on like Neo Marx Neo
Neo Marxism post-modern is like [__] I
know that the dummies that watch your
[__] don't have any idea what you're
talking about and I'm pretty sure you
don't have any idea what you're talking
about so Richard Wolff that's his um
specialty
is uh
economics and specifically like Marxism
right
uh
yes are you talking about Richard Wolff
yes sorry I was literally opening up a
new Google doc so I have my before I
forget like I was trying to write down
some of the questions that I have for
him okay
um that I have collected in my mind
apologies for that Richard Wolff is a
famous marxian economist obviously there
aren't that many of them out there which
is all been hunted well no literally I
mean McCarthyism is like a a big part of
why this is like a a very contentious
subject even though it shouldn't be
um he's Luke Skywalker we'll get into a
little bit but like
you'll see a lot more
marxists or some kind of socialist in
other departments usually sociology
maybe philosophy uh not necessarily so
in philosophy but
um rarely ever in the economy side of
things because uh the the uh economics
departments and the finance departments
have a uh have a neoclassical economics
uh stronghold
so they consider anything beyond that
like the furthest I guess quote-unquote
left you'll go in neoclassical economics
is is uh Keynesian economics and beyond
that it's considered like
unorthodox not real magic Alchemy you
know what I mean
well so so that that is I think the
unique part of this he's but he's highly
tenured I mean he was a economics
professor at Yale yeah he has a crazy uh
uh pedigree anyway here he is uh
reacting to some of Jordan's absolute
nonsense
this is one of the things that's so
great about the way the Americans set up
their political system because through
the magic of the internet it is possible
for me to respond to some things that
were said by a Canadian psychologist by
the name of Jordan Peterson who teaches
at the University I love that he had to
preface this by like through only
through the magic of the internet
yeah it's it's called a duet uh
professor
talking about the psychology he teaches
or that he preaches because that's not
my area of expertise just as it's clear
that Marxism is not his however he has
made statements about Marxism despite
not knowing very much about it as is
evident from what he says uh and these
have included daring Marxist to debate
with him just for the record anytime
anywhere as long as we can work out the
details uh no problem at this end by the
way an aside four years ago they were
supposed to debate Jordan and Professor
wolf yeah
um and then Jordan bitched out and
demanded fifty thousand dollars from a
small University philosophy Department
to host the debate after it had already
been arranged so that's actually not
surprising because a giant coward no
here's what here's what they do China
right-wing commentators do this all the
time and in most circumstances it's not
like the young Republicans club that
actually has that kind of money but it's
actually donors of the University alumni
that are right-wing and want Ben Shapiro
to go to that college to you know I
guess uh educate the youth that will
facilitate that they will usually pay
him like that that speaker's fee is
actually on the lower end from what I
understand 50 yes uh now obviously this
was many many years ago so I don't know
he might have he might have been
suggesting that simply to duck out like
the coward that he is I could see it
both ways but you're right in that like
Ben Shapiro's not gonna [__] go out
of the kindness of his heart and talk to
some kids no these guys don't do that
yeah yeah yeah no that's not a that's
not interesting so we don't we don't get
those fat juicy checks here on the left
not that I would have anything to tell a
university but he certainly would yeah
when I I mean every time I've ever been
invited to a college campus or anything
like of like that I've always done for
free like there's no I've never
I guess with the exception of politicon
which was debates uh I've never gotten
paid for a speaking engagement that's it
that's what I expect right it's almost
like a community service you're going to
talk to the kids yeah but for the right
it's actually and not even just the
right like Hillary Clinton makes a lot
of money doing this like politicians do
it makes sense in a way yeah I mean it's
just like uh it's like you know
so anyway it doesn't have anything going
on that's worth 750 000 for once no no
no like what the [__] but what's funny
is that Jordan challenged him to a
debate he accepted and then he bitched
out and said I need 50k but anyway here
it is
so what is it that's wrong with what Mr
Peterson has to say about Marxism well
it's partly that he's recycling old Cold
War stuff the Cold War was over in 1989.
most of us have moved on around the
world Mr Peterson seems to be stuck and
he's stuck with one of the oldest kinds
of arguments imaginable telling us that
we should not be interested in Marxism
in fact it's kind of immoral in his
words to be interested in Marxism in
view of what Stalin did in Soviet Russia
well okay Stalin did Terrible Things in
Soviet Russia however Marxism exists in
every country in the face of the Earth
it's been going on for 150 years and a
lot more than what happened in Russia
under Stalin over a period of 15 or 20
years has to be taken into account if
you're going to make an assessment of
Marxism to use the one example that is
really horrible over there as the
judgment on Marxism would be about the
same sense as saying Christianity should
be dismissed because of the Catholic
Inquisition or the destruction of the
Native American population by Christians
or the Holocaust against Jews gays uh
and so forth by Christians in Germany
and on and on and on two world wars by
capitalist Christian countries fighting
each other may all qualify for the kinds
of argument Mr Peterson makes we don't
make those kinds of arguments because
they make no sense and Mr Peterson ought
to do that with Marxism the only other
thing to say is he seems to reduce
Marxism when he actually talks about it
to the problem of inequality that some
people are rich and others are poor and
he deals with that by the very
sophisticated notion that poor people's
anger at rich is their Envy of the
success this is an insult to those folks
who are critical of inequality but
apparently Mr Peterson doesn't worry
about that so let to respond inequality
is indeed a social problem but it has
nothing particularly to do with Marxism
people have been talking about the
problem of inequality for thousands of
years before there ever was a Karl Marx
or a Marxism the whole point of Marxism
was to explain why inequality under
capitalism didn't go away and let's
remind everybody capitalism comes into
the world and the French and American
Revolutions talking about being better
than feudalism because under capitalism
you see we are free we are equal we are
democratic and all the rest of it
capitalism was to bring in the words of
the French Revolution Liberty equality
and fraternity well as you know and I
know and even Mr Peterson must know we
have capitalism we sure do but we don't
have freedom equality and fraternity not
even close Mr Peterson's own speech is
in education of that so the marxists
have always said why is that why do we
not have the equality that capitalism
promised and the answer is in the
analysis of capitalism the way in which
capitalism organizes Society with
employers and employees the kind of
parallel to Lords and serfs and Masters
and slaves such that the employees
produce the wealth that the capitalists
get into their hands thereby becoming
wealthier while the mass of the working
people are excluded from the very
Surplus their creativity
puts on this Earth in other words
there's an explanation if Mr Peterson
understood that his critique of
capitalism might address that
explanation okay pause it for a second
act as though there is no explanation
so wolf pack so you watch the [__]
five minute Tick Tock video I well yeah
dude I watched this whole thing that's
insane and I was like this guy [__]
rules dude okay just shows how good he
is and five minutes on Tick Tock is
entirely too long and I I will be the
first to say it I actually I'm gonna
disagree with you I've been watching
longer Tick Tock videos and I like
actually I I have two because like I use
tick tock when I'm pooping okay okay
yeah and it's actually it's actually
great when like there's like a five
minute one so you can just like let it
run
and then not have to touch your phone
right but I I find myself like when it
was a minute I'm like I want more of
this when it's like a dude cutting a
cow's hoof or something which is my
favorite right now and you want so
you've been watching a lot bro have you
seen those those farriers I I have
watched them before yeah they dig out
like absence from the cows huff and [__]
so [__] did not have this
conversation with you where I said I've
done that to a horse and I've never cut
the hoofs but like you know cleaning the
hoof is like one of the things that's
pretty basic part of like working on a
ranch or just having right yes you did
right right I guess we've had this
camera and then you said that that's not
the same
no I'm not I'm not I've never like I've
never actually shaved a hoof or anything
like that then what so what's the point
of even saying it because because I've
cleaned out the hoof though like you
clean out the hoof that's just a stick
you just put take out mud from the
Horseshoe not a stick these guys are
like surgical like I I've
yeah you're right it's just yeah I
polish it you know what I mean like I've
done I've done all that I've done hoof
maintenance
okay hoof maintenance
so anyway
um he's the man don't take this away
from me
well listen I uh you're just jealous
because you've never touched a hook
that's like me standing in front of uh
you know no it's cool man you just never
you've never touched the hook it's fine
I mean I respect what you do but I'm not
gonna stand in front of like the Mona
Lisa and be like I could do that
okay what that's not you
hey these guys are Masters it really
goes to show how you feel about the the
hoof repair
they're awesome they're the they're
doing the Mona Lisa every time yes
yeah so um we I've prepared a bunch of
Clips I kind of want to get his take on
he's
um he's the man I got one I got a bunch
from Jordan I got some from Dennis
Prager my man should we ask about the
incest one should we cue that up what's
your argument I mean I have a lot of
questions
riding a horse at the young lad I have a
lot of questions for it that is
literally I thought you were gonna do
with me no that's actually me
yeah I won I won that tournament yeah
yeah I got a ribbon are you serious yeah
I don't want to say it but
glow up gay oh yeah I used to the
funniest part about that is I used to
think
I used to hate dressing like that
because like when you're especially when
you're young it's like the worst but you
have to you have to wear a blazer you
have to wear a suit with a tie and
everything I used to hate dressing up
like that and now you know become gay
now I I do it on my own volition
I wear tight tights when I'm working out
every day like compression pants so did
you own a horse yeah
your family rich or some [__] yeah my
family used to be oh yeah I've talked
about this oh I didn't know that yeah my
my uh so I there's a generational curse
oh okay there's a generational person
both sides of my family Dave yes okay
they they always I remember they always
make a lot of money like they have
historically always made a lot of money
and then literally went bankrupt by the
time they're next of kin uh reaches
College age which is literally what
happened to me I ask you and what are
you afraid that you're gonna fall to the
same curse
maybe I mean I I am not
I'm not like them they they're both my
grandfather and my dad were like well my
dad made a lot of like risky like he
just was doing like Futures Trading and
[__] which is so stupid and
uh my my grandfather was just like more
so kind of a baller in the sense that he
he had like one big
he had like one big court case I think
where he got like a lot of uh real
estate my great this is my grandfather
who's been dead for many many years and
then he just basically
sold all of those properties and then
lived off the money for the rest of his
life you hear that music what is that
that's the curse music oh Jesus Christ
the third the third is coming how would
you lose all your money I wonder both
how would Hassan go broke
um I don't know I [__] get
like Omega canceled or something
canceled
yeah so much so that like I can no
longer uh continue to make content but
even then like I don't know
yeah well the question is will you be
able to afford your children a horse
that's kind of the status that we're
going for I will not do that I will not
do that for my children anyway because
like honestly
uh I I Loki kind of hated it when I was
okay so there he was more like it I
wanted to play basketball but my parent
like this was something that they wanted
me to do
well you could have been a whole
different world you playing basketball
yeah I mean I I ended up playing
basketball as well uh because my horse
died
oh yeah
um what do you do with the horse when it
dies
I don't know I probably Glue Factory
right now make it do eat it no jerky no
no this is such a big animal you know
you gotta what do you do with it there's
a lot of meat I don't know I I think I
want to waste her I guess I don't know
I actually don't know okay so we're
we're run out of time I wanted to talk I
wanted to talk at least about Rudy
Giuliani
pulling up a [__] is he in the chat Dan
yeah so then let's do it we'll do it
afterwards yeah we'll have time after
yeah we'll have time afterwards so all
right let me get it set up one second
let's not waste our AB has some facts on
this all the horses when they die must
be disposed of immediately with very few
exceptions and they must be delivered to
a premise approved for proper collection
and Disposal what happens if they're not
it says they must be disposed
immediately like they're going to raise
your Dynasty gets cursed going broke
generation after generation how do you
think it happened to the song yeah yeah
but for real why is it like so they're
like yo you better kill you gotta get
rid of that fast honestly the more I
think about the generational curse thing
tomorrow I'm like they all lived awesome
lives
like uh my my grandparents and my dad
who's still alive uh they're they're
fine so I don't even I don't even mind
it if that were to happen to me uh
Professor hello can you see and hear us
yes I can hear you fine awesome thanks
for joining us my pleasure you know I
have to say I'm a I'm a new fan of yours
I'm I'm uh I I found your content on
Tick Tock what do you think about that
well I'm glad you got in there before
the people who want to shut it down to
take it away
okay that's interesting what do you
think about the tick tock shutdown
that's kind of a good it's a good that's
a good way to start but Professor will
watch out he's he's a liberal the man
you're speaking to
he's he's saying he likes your videos
but he's he's a big he's a big business
owner and a liberal I'm just letting you
know okay well I'm I'm I'm suitably
forewarned I shall be terribly terribly
careful okay yes uh I'll have you know
I'm stealing your labor right now he's
he's right he's an open-minded one
though he is an open-minded liberal yeah
so what do you actually I I I'm
um
I find the whole uh pursuit to shut down
Tick Tock a little bit or it's all kind
of bad faith in my opinion it all seems
like a bunch of BS what are your
thoughts
yeah I would agree with that I I I
understand why it's being done I
understand that uh many of the things
that are happening in the economy which
is what I study uh have to do with
um a rather desperate effort of the
United States to reverse uh history that
doesn't usually work out real well and I
don't expect it's going to work out real
well this time either
but it's a way for plea politicians to
Pander and they don't usually miss a
chance to doing that if it gives them
some Advantage right Professor what
would you say to people that uh
are are possibly speculating that this
is an effort uh by uh big Tech to
basically use xenophobia to effectively
uh shut out a market competitor that has
been really dominant a market competitor
that is not uh obviously owned by
Silicon Valley that doesn't offer the
same back doors even though it offers a
similar uh backdoors I would suspect but
not the same ones
um that uh that Silicon Valley Tech
Giants would offer
people claim that this is uh this is
done to erode competition
look my experience uh over many many
years is that act actions like this
never have one or two causes they are
decisions that are made that meet a
bunch of criteria or if you like respond
to a variety of causes any one of which
wouldn't have been enough to make it
happen but it's the whole collection of
them that make it happen so yeah one of
the factors going into the tick tock
decision was the convenient way you can
have the government favor one competitor
over others it is often arranged by
those other competitors to get rid of
the one that they don't like or that
they can all agree on getting rid of and
so that becomes part of the story you
could see that already or this helps you
figure it out by going after the Huawei
corporation which produced last year in
the year before for things that compete
with American companies so this was a
convenient way before the general
Onslaught against China really got going
uh to strike a blow to get some support
for sitting politicians from those who
benefit by getting rid of Huawei and the
same thing with uh Tick Tock it seems to
me that all this kind of Boogeyman
threat about China harvesting our data
seems kind of silly I I don't know I'm
not a technologist but it just doesn't I
don't see how that is any bigger of a
threat than anyone else who's harvesting
our data I mean if China wanted data
they just buy it from Facebook exactly
they they would like it's probably
cheaper for them to go to through data
Brokers yeah to like operate servers
it's all there already so I don't know
it seems a little bit uh
are a lot a bit bad faith are you are
you familiar with the resist bill that's
uh the resist act that's coming out uh
in the aftermath of this uh this debacle
in Congress
no tell me about it
um so there is now a uh or not resist
sorry restrict I I messed it up the
restrict act that is uh being promoted
um there's a lot of speculation on what
it could potentially do is this
vagueness surrounding it but it's
proposed legislation that was first
introduced in the United States Senate
on March 7th to authorize
get this the Secretary of Commerce
uh to review and prohibit certain
transactions between persons in the
United States and foreign adversaries
and the foreign adversaries list is of
course uh you know the the same villains
quote unquote uh ranging from Iran to
Venezuela to China and Russia of course
um and uh people are fearful that you
can be fined up to a million dollars and
also with 20 years uh prison sentence
for uh if they if they consider you to
be doing something illegal like
utilizing
again this is vague they claim that it's
not going to hit vpns but using vpns for
example or or even using Tick Tock this
came after uh this was directed towards
tick tock if they ban Tick Tock you can
go to jail for using tick tock
that's technically okay
it's a better start you better start
building prisons why
well yeah well that is a big well you
know but the interest I'm glad you
brought it up the interesting thing
about this is
from an economics point of view
it's kind of remarkable you know
um
I've lived all my life in the United
States I was born in Ohio and been
working here all my life and I grew up
at a time when when we were told in the
economics courses I took in the
universities where I've taught economics
all my life that an economy works best
if it's private and if the government
doesn't enter in do this do that
regulate this choose one company over
another we were told literally that this
is a bad thing to be avoided at all
costs so I think it's one important
thing is to recognize that all of that
stuff has been thrown out the window in
the last five or ten years just as if it
were never spoken as if it were never
taught even though it was the dominant
ideological
statement of what western capitalism was
all about and you're now seeing it used
to be it used to be a phrase the
government should not choose winners and
losers in the market that was a kind of
phrase that we were told well what
you're seeing at every turn
is exactly the opposite the government
is choosing winners and losers helping
these industries not those Industries
saving this one not the other one
forbidding this allowing that it's never
stopping and it's not a sign of
confidence in your system it's a sign of
fear and Retreat and danger and
isolation and now let me put on my
economics hat
you know it's not that list that you
mentioned a minute ago Iran Russia China
you better get out your pencil because
that list is becoming longer and longer
and longer with each passing day
it used to be Russia China and we would
you know have the usual socialist bad
guys or communist bad guys but now we
have all kinds of societies the
important thing to remember is something
called The Bricks
b-r-i-c-s Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa
we are isolating ourselves from them
by pretending we are isolating them but
that's not the way it's working the rest
of the world is gathering around them
not us
and the make-believe that that's not the
case is a dangerous form of
self-delusion in the United States
look the war in here in Ukraine whatever
else you think of it was supposed to be
over in a short time once the sanctions
got going they were called the mother of
all sanctions they would bring Russia to
its knees go back and look at the the
press in February March and April of
last year that's what they were
predicting none of that has happened
none of it and why because it turned out
that Russia which is a weak economic
system and was before this War started
but Russia has a really big and powerful
friends more of them each day and they
turn to those friends and they made a
bad joke out of the mother of all
sanctions which hasn't stopped the war
one eye Oda and adding more tanks and
sending more shells isn't gonna change
that these are more and more looking
like the acts of people who took a
really bad turn
cannot admit it cannot face it and keep
doubling down in a way that makes the
rest of the world shake their head and
more and more of us inside the United
States scratching our head and wondering
what are you doing
what are you doing and and that's really
where people like me now that's where we
find ourselves
what kind of policy is it that you would
like to see in terms of uh like how how
American America responded to the war in
Ukraine instead of sanctions
sure
I think the best way is actually to
remind everybody about American history
right at a certain point back in the
18th century the 19 the people here in
the United States decided that they were
sick and tired of being a colony of
Great Britain so we broke away from the
British Empire we did that by means of a
violent revolution we fought a war with
England 1776 we've all learned about it
in school
um teen times
we know and and an amazing thing
happened
the British Empire which at that time
ruled the world
the slogan in England at that time was
the Sun never sets on the British Empire
because we've got the whole world
covered from India to Africa to you know
the story okay to the amazement of
everybody
the British were defeated by the
Americans in that Revolutionary War
but they didn't give up in 1812 we had
another War where the British Empire
decided again to try to squash the new
emerging economic power of the United
States
two Wars they were defeated both times
finally the British got the memo
this not gonna work you are not gonna
undo the history uh that you yourself
helped to make
so what you ought to do is sit down and
work out with the United States this new
car get over your upset that your Empire
isn't growing anymore get over it
recognize that your Empire is now on the
downturn and that a new power is arising
namely the United States and they worked
out a peace agreement that lasted a
century
okay you want my answer that's what we
ought to be doing with Russia and China
not go to one little war or not so
little one proxy war next we'll have a
war that isn't the proxy war you know
we're on the edge of it anyway almost
every day we'll do something in the
South China Sea we'll provoke one way or
another or we will be provoked
this is a dead end it's it's not in our
interest it's not in their interest we
need to live with this new emerging
economic power we don't need to keep
trying to squash it it doesn't work
every other Empire
Greek Roman British Persian
ottoman you go through them they all had
a ride up then they plateaued and then
they went down the last hundred years
has been the American Empire
especially after World War II it was a
great ride up for the U.S it's going to
be a bumpy difficult ride down and the
sooner we face it the better our
judgments will be and the better our
policies will be because where we are
going
whether it's Ukraine or Banning
Tick-Tock or hounding Huawei
these are things that are going to hurt
the US I keep trying to explain the
people when Saudi Arabia
shifts its oil resources from the West
to China and Russia and this is a
screaming signal uh oh even the people
you thought were most dependent on you
aren't anymore
and unless you're blind or blinded by
some ideological reflex your ought to
outgrow
you're going to be making one mistake
after another and people like you and me
are going to be talking about them even
though we would wish we didn't have to
and I think your answer is collaborative
multi-polarity like leaning into that uh
with with all of the other uh hegemonic
powers or at least like uh superpowers
that are growing uh at a rapid Pace the
propaganda though that I think a lot of
people consume in America is that these
countries are not willing to work with
us it's them that's putting up the
roadblocks but they are working with us
we're working with them all day every
day I mean we couldn't have we have no
Commerce without China
listen let me give you a couple of just
simple statistics throughout the entire
anti-chinese or China bashing or
whatever you want to call it of the last
eight or nine years beginning at the end
uh of Obama
right through the Tariff and trade Wars
of trump and now the continuation under
the neocons working with Biden
throughout that time the trade between
the United States and China goes up
every single year there's a peculiar
disconnect between if you pardon me the
Roaring [__] from the politicians
and the underlying reality
that we need them we need them to
produce consumer goods if the American
people had not been able to buy cheap
Chinese consumer goods over the last 30
years
they would have demanded and they would
have gotten higher wages to pay what
would have been the price if those
things had been produced anywhere else
capitalists in America are grateful if
they're honest
for the cheap Chinese Goods that have
made it possible for profits to go up
without Rising wages because you could
go to your neighborhood TJ Maxx store
and buy inexpensive Chinese clothing or
to the other stores you know there is no
Amazon there is no Walmart without
Chinese Goods if you block if you plot
the growth of Walmart and the growth of
China you discover something it's the
same business that China can out produce
us on everything but they could never
have gotten into the American Market
unless Walmart Target and all the others
acted eagerly to be the distributor of
those Chinese goods and to make a
fortune for themselves along the way
those are the realities the rest is make
believe
nobody wants this war in Ukraine above
all the people of Ukraine who are
suffering beyond all words the
destruction of their society who's
benefiting out of this
I mean American weapons manufacturers
yes
excuse me the American weapons
manufacturers are yep yep it seems like
uh those with the least to lose and the
most to gain out of this are the ones
that are pushing for it and pushing for
the continuation of it uh whether it be
Boris Johnson uh back when he was the
Prime Minister going into uh Ukraine
during uh the first round of Peace
negotiations or a possible ceasefire and
peace negotiation talks that were
happening
um organized by turkey or whether it be
uh you know Ned price and numerous other
American State Department officials uh
continuously talking about how uh they
are not interested in peace at all
um obviously there's an argument here
about what ukrainians uh want and some
will say that well the overwhelming
majority of ukrainians want to keep
fighting this fight but ultimately uh we
are not giving ukrainians everything
they want it's not like we're uh you
know implementing Article Five we're not
uh we're not even giving ukrainians
f-16s we're not training them on that we
might down the line I think but so far
these are demands that they've made that
we haven't uh conceded to so um you know
I think that uh pushing for peace
negotiations on that front uh with China
and Russia at the other side of the
table with Ukraine and the United States
of America on one side of the table
would be the quickest and most Swift way
to try to stop uh this conflict and and
further Bloodshed from continuing
well I mean let me just expand one one
dimension of of that point we now have a
defense budget depending a little bit on
how you look at it in the neighborhood
of 850 billion to a trillion dollars
it if you take a look it's more money
than the next eight or nine countries in
the world combined spend on their
military
we have just authorized an additional
100 plus billion dollars just for the
war in Ukraine
even if you believe that one motivation
for the Ukraine war is the money being
made by the defense industry
we already are doing more than anyone in
their right mind could ask to provide
them with a profitable business
over a trillion dollar I don't even
think they're that greedy
they are getting a bundle a big bundle
with no opposition nobody opposes uh the
defense budget I mean a handful of
people but it's basically trivial the
two parties that run our politics are
both eager to outdo one another in
supporting the defense budget they're in
very good shape they don't need another
100 billion dollar war on top of the
gift that this one represents so I for
me I don't I think it's even them I
wouldn't mind criticizing them if I
thought it but I I don't see they're
already they've made a ton of money by
all this stuff we've shipped to Ukraine
and all of that will have to be replaced
they will get the money and the profit
out of that uh the budget is huge and it
got a tremendous boost look I'm an
economist and he
two things have happened in the last
year that strike me as downright funny
we are in a supposed war against the
inflation in our country and to that end
we have a Federal Reserve our Central
Bank that has raised interest rates and
that's supposed to slow down the
spending by individuals and businesses
because they can't it's too expensive to
borrow money at high interest rates
etc
etc what's the worst thing you can do to
an inflation pour money onto it it's
like squeezing a kerosene on a campfire
it flares up as a stupid thing to do
what have we just done we have just
spent an extra 100 billion dollars on a
war in Ukraine most of that money goes
right back into the American economy
because it pays for the military one way
or another and Mr zielinski is not
stupid he understands you better spend
that money back in the United States and
not in some other country because that
will be the fastest way to cut that uh
game over number one the second thing we
did when our banks started to collapse a
couple weeks ago was to say that the
Federal Reserve is going to come in and
give any Bank in trouble
losing deposits they can go to the
Federal Reserve and borrow brand new
money to replace the deposits but let me
explain to you if the deposits go from a
troubled Bank to an untroubled bank
that's still money circulating in our
economy if the federal reserve backstops
banks by pumping more in money in then
you've got a bank crisis leading to more
money and a war leading to more money
you're not slowing down the inflation
that way you're making it worse what's
my point it's obvious no one discusses
it in this country no one is saying wait
a minute wait a minute we got to think
about the inflationary if we propose to
get to help the food stamp recipients
for another six months the issue of
inflation would be raised yeah that's a
moral hazard it's only a moral hazard as
it pertains to the Working Poor when
you're helping uh the Working Poor it's
never a moral hazard when you're helping
bankers get golden parachutes in the
aftermath of the 2008 financial uh
collapse
um so what you're what you're basically
just to make it a little bit easier to
understand for our audience here uh am I
correct in in stating that we we have
two methods of dealing with the
inflation we have monetary policy and
fiscal policy uh fiscal policy conducted
by the legislative branch which is
usually just completely powerless with
the exception of the bipartisanship that
they always find when it uh comes down
to more money for the military and then
you the monetary policy is also uh one
that you can use and it's pretty much
the only one that uh you can use is uh
unfortunately because there is no such
uh deflationary uh Physical policy that
the the Republicans or the Democrats
will ever allow so they're they're
utilizing that uh the control over the
inflation uh by by controlling the
interest rates uh with it with the
express purpose of depressing wages
kicking people out of jobs with the
hopes that like inevitably people will
be
this tight labor market will turn back
around and and you will have a labor
force that's willing and able to take uh
less pay for the same work
yeah and again I don't mean to beat a
dead horse here but again
I'm astonished I'm an economics I'm
astonished that the only way we are
discussing as a nation
dealing with the inflation is by raising
interest rates which will throw millions
of people out of work and everybody
knows that which will probably hurt the
poorest amongst us most the last hired
the first fire all of that again
worsening uh the disparities of our
racial community of our ethnic community
of the genders and on and on really
we're going to go through that I'm a
professor I learned that there are other
methods of dealing with inflation can we
talk about that can we talk about it do
not involve raising interest rates
I am mystified why I live in a country
where the people in charge know what I
just said
and they refuse to discuss it we have a
country in which raising interest rates
is considered like the thing the only
thing and all that's left for us to
discuss is how many you know percentage
points it'll go up or down how soon
let me drive it home in a personal way
but people seem to like this so I'll
tell you this story I got my PhD in
economics at Yale University
at the time I got it it was almost all
uh men who were student women didn't go
into economics then they do much more
now but they didn't
so there were two or three women in my
class and we all got to know them
because they were only two or three
women in my class and one of them who
took the same courses I did in the same
classroom I did from the same Professor
I did you know was a woman you've gotten
to know her name is Janet Yellen so I
know what she knows she knows what I
know we were schoolmates we went to the
same graduate program in that program we
learned that one of the most interesting
ways to stop an inflation that has been
used in many countries at many times
often with great success
and that was used August 15
1971 by the sitting president Richard M
Nixon
he got on television and he said to the
American people
we've got a terrible inflation here's
how we're going to deal with it
as of right now as he was speaking on
radio and TV any business that raises
its price we're gonna come for you we're
gonna rescue and you're going to jail
any Union or other worker organization
that pushes or tries to push the wage up
we will do the same to you this policy
is called in this country a wage price
freeze in other countries it's called an
incomes policy because it freezes the
income of the employer and the income of
the employee at the same time wherever
it happens to stand
that was originally put into effect for
90 days it was extended it brought the
inflation down it is an alternative it
has its strengths and weaknesses just
like raising interest rates but they're
different and an honest Society trying
to deal honestly with its problems would
have a debate publicly about these
Alternatives and by the way there are
others I could give you if you were
interested it's not the only two there's
more than two but we live in a society
that has a quick dismissal
if they even admit well I just explain
to you which is in every history book
and can be verified in 10 minutes of
Googling anything
there's no excuse for what's going on
just like breezily dismissing the the
Ukraine war by saying the Russians and
the Chinese don't offer to sit down and
have a ceasefire both of those countries
have done it maybe they're lying maybe
they'd cop out once you started the
process but we're not in a very good
position to call them bluffers if we
haven't called The Bluff and if we're
willing to sit down without conditions
why don't we say so and I don't think
you can use the argument about what the
ukrainians want because I I hear I'm not
interested in criticizing Mr zielinski
but you should know if you don't that he
has shut down opposition newspapers
opposition media opposition politicians
uh he's fighting a war maybe you have to
do that in war but there is no way to
know what the mass of the Ukrainian
people feel unless you want to take the
fact that some somewhere between six and
seven million of them have left the
country and it's not that big a country
and that would not be a sign that you
would want to make a big argument about
that this shows that they're in favor of
fighting to the last Ukrainian since
they've made a choice not to be among
those last ukrainians that that we're
fighting for so it does strike me as is
an awful lot of accumulated evidence
that we're not dealing honestly and
straightly with these major problems of
our society and that's usually the sign
of a society that is scared shitless if
you pardon my Spanish and therefore is
functioning with a level of anxiety that
is scary to watch
um getting back to fiscal policy and
monetary policy uh you talked about some
things that have demonstrably worked
like the Nixon price freeze uh for
contemporary America uh for Contemporary
American society do you have any
suggestions on fiscal policy that would
be deflationary
um and and can we even Implement these
policies
absolutely the first policy that would
be deflationary uh and it is long
overdue is raising taxes on corporations
in the rich
if you want it very concrete reverse the
tax cuts that were passed in December of
2017. the biggest single economic Act of
recent history
uh was that tax cut that is what
produced the trillion dollar deficits
we've had ever since we had deficits
before it's not that we didn't but we
took a Quantum Leap
and let me let me drive home the 2017
tax cuts benefiting mostly corporations
in the rich came at the end of a 30-year
period maybe even 40 years yeah of a
dramatic
boom in profits of a dramatic increase
in the inequality of wealth those were
two arguments that said this was the
last thing you needed to do corporations
were rolling in money that's why we had
the greatest peacetime stock market boom
in the 80s 90s and into the first decade
of this Century they didn't need it they
didn't they shouldn't have got it the
people who deserved it were the ones who
had come out on the short end of the
stick over the 80s 90s in the first
decade of this Century if you wanted to
help someone help them but if you didn't
want to help them okay but shoveling
vast amounts of money into the hands of
those who needed them least
was an incredibly if you pardon me
stupid
it was so greedy it it lopped over
Beyond greed into downright stupid okay
and then and then to scratch your head
and say gee we have terrible deficits
well what the hell did you think you'd
get with a tax cut it's like today
saying you know we have a shortage of
Labor hello you just kicked out millions
of immigrants they were doing that work
what are you surprised by the results of
what you did were you born yesterday
um I wanted to ask about
um
go ahead okay well all right well I got
I got some more questions or at least uh
uh your opinion on one of my suggestions
I think uh stock BuyBacks uh used to be
considered Market manipulation and that
consideration was correct in my opinion
it is it is Market manipulation
um and uh they used to be illegal until
1982. uh I think that one other uh
immediate uh so not a full-blown
solution but one other immediate uh form
of legislation could come by making
stock BuyBacks illegal again especially
at a time when you know uh corporations
uh are very clearly only beholden to
their shareholders even the world
economic forum and uh and other uh
capitalists are talking about how they
need to find a new capitalism to a
stakeholder uh focused uh solution to to
the economic problems um I think that's
that's one other that's one other thing
that we could absolutely be considering
as well
yes I do not I agree with you but I I
hate to throw water on your little
campfire here so I'm gonna agree with
you that uh stock buy but they certainly
are a market manipulation that's that's
why they're done uh their goal is to
boost the price of the stock in the
market uh the company by going in and
being a major buyer uh has the effect of
driving up the price of the stock if you
remember that members of the board of
directors of many companies hi
Executives in many companies are paid
with stock options and other kinds of
stock remuneration then you can see they
have a personal interest and a personal
gain by using the company's money to
drive up the price of the shares they
have but here's the water I'm gonna
throw a little bit
corporations understand what we're
saying the general public maybe not but
the people who run the larger
corporations hire economists and
accountants like me who explain this to
them and you know maybe not the first or
third or ninth time but by the 15th time
we go over it they kind of get it
um and they can keep it in mind because
it's their wallet
but they have developed over the years a
whole host of strategies and If you deny
them this one and I'm in favor of it I
agree with you I would support it but
I'm I've been around now and I will tell
you they have dozens of other strategies
that will accomplish more or less the
same thing oh absolutely I'll give you
one example just so you get the flavor
company a a big multi-billion dollar
company and Company B another one and
they get together over golf
or at the fanciest restaurant they can
find
and they come to an agreement company a
uses its profits to buy shares in
Company B that's not a stock buyback
and Company B uses its profits you get
the picture to buy the stock of company
a I've watched it it's there it's a
strategy and I could go on and as long
as we allow a tiny group of people a
board of directors you know 15 20 human
beings sitting at the top of these Mega
corporations as long as you give them
the authority of disposing of the
billions of dollars in profits in
revenues that they have at their
disposal
you can't be surprised if they use it to
enrich themselves that's how the game of
capitalism is organized the rest of us
are supposed to be Spectators and go oh
and ah when they use the money to
aggrandize you know themselves or their
companies they really do have lovely
Shrubbery around their headquarters I
want to say there's at a certain point
and kind of goes back to what we were
talking about before when you know
during a 40-year period of you know huge
profits they give themselves another
massive tax cut it like you said it's
stupid but it's even worse than that
it's almost like self-defeating great
greed to the point where it's
destabilizing Society is going to end up
eventually with their head on a pike you
know what I mean or their head in a
[__] in a goddamn Ethan is
recognizing the contradictions professor
wolf that's what's going on are their
head in a guillotines like how is it
that they're not aware they must be
aware of where they're going and at a
certain point I just don't understand
why they don't acknowledge that I can be
ultra rich and also it's as important
that we live in a stable Society where
someone's not gonna people are gonna
come eat me
okay
let me answer it by telling you a story
since I am a graduate of the fancy
schools in this country
and and have all the connections that
those schools
create for you when you go through them
the education you get by the way is
quite mediocre at the connections they
are super yeah
all right I have therefore been at the
following conversation
a group of people sitting on the boards
of directors of the biggest corporations
in America
some of them talk like you just did they
say things like well I'll quote you
Warren Buffett will it say in public I
pay a lower rate of taxes on my billions
than my secretary does on what we pay
her remember he said that he got a lot
of play so he gets it
he gets it that it's stupid what they're
doing it's self-destructive what they're
doing and he appeals to the other
directors like him to see what he's
saying and he's not the only one
but the problem is there's another group
of directors who come right back at him
and say the following the mass of people
in this country are too divided
to disorganized and too ignorant
to figure any of this out I say that
they're that they say that
uh malignant it's just evil
look if you keep sticking it I'm gonna
defend them now
but I'm only answering your question I
don't mean to defend them but I am going
to defend them because here's the way it
goes
once you're once you get over your anger
that they talk like think like that
which I get you're going to ask yourself
because you're a smart guy why I mean
you know people aren't born that way why
would they think and talk like that and
here's the answer
they were Warren Buffett's in the past
they warned in their company look let's
not go so far let's give the workers a
decent pay let's you know pay our taxes
let's spend some money to make the city
nicer for people or whatever
and they got shot down by the let's call
them for lack of a better term the
conservative type pro-business types
they got shot down and the pro-business
guys stuck it to the workers some more
and evaded the taxes some more and
didn't give a nickel to the community
and guess what
the profits of the company went up
because there was no reaction
the local politicians didn't do anything
the people didn't get the pitchforks
they didn't March down Main Street with
them none of it
and so over time they began to feel as
though they're let's call it Humane
impulsor whatever you want to call it to
be nice guys as employers was a mistake
made them look like they were uh weak or
in some way not as gung-ho to make a
profit for the company uh as their as
their fellow directors they didn't want
to take that kind of risk they didn't
want that kind of reputation they kind
of swallowed their bad feeling
they stopped telling their wife about
how they felt because the wife would
notice that if you felt that way in the
past you're not feeling that way now I
don't hear you say anything about doing
good for the community you've got me
sitting on the the board of the local y
or the orchestra or the local charity
but you're not coming to the meetings
and you're not even asking me anymore so
what you've got is a is a
a capitalist employer class
whose majority thinks they can safely
ignore the mass repercussions nothing
will happen the Republicans and the
Democrats will distract people away from
what we're doing to them economically
they'll get more interested in I don't
know immigrants or being carrying a gun
or whether transgender people can use
the toilet
we don't have to worry about
sadly that doesn't make sense so what is
the what is the most effective mechanism
of pushback in your opinion uh
it's exactly what we were just talking
about let me give you an example as I'm
speaking to you in three countries
in three countries of Europe
is the answer
France Germany and Greece
in all of those countries masses of
people are letting the power structure
there both the political power structure
and the business uh leadership know that
there are limits in France they are
telling the president Mr macron you are
not going to solve the fiscal Troubles
of France by depriving them people of
two years of their pension you're not
going to do that we're not gonna let you
in Germany all the railroad stations and
all the airports are closed because the
workers are on strike and the issue
there is the inflation you are not going
to jack up the price of oil and gas for
all of us and then not change our wages
I mean you're not we're not going to
tolerate and Greece you might find is
even the most interesting
four weeks ago they had a terrible train
wreck worse than the one we had in East
Palestine Ohio but around the same time
it killed 60 young people among other
things
and they went into the streets to
denounce the privatization of the rail
system in their country the government
came down on them and so now they're all
against the government
this is making everybody stop and pay
real close attention the polls in France
my father was French I speak French I
have since I've been a kid
um the polls in France are about 60 to
65 percent
supporting the people in the streets so
there is no escape from the president uh
for him he's in a deep deep
container of doo doo and with very
little mechanism to get out of it well
what you're what you're describing also
uh I can't uh I have to mention this but
what you're describing is three nations
that uh even even with Greece that have
a higher rate of participation in unions
in the labor force with a stronger
history of of uh you know labor
uprisings and also like even when you
consider France for example even if they
do not have uh actual card carrying
union members they have collective
bargaining agreements that Encompass
damn near the entirety of the economy in
Francis I believe 98 collective
bargaining agreements yes and they're
and they're industry-wide I mean yeah
the unions get together the employers
get together they bargain across the
table and it covers the entire industry
across the country whereas uh one fact
that I like to always point to in the
United States of America is the union
participation rate in this country is
actually even lower than a country that
we destroyed we eviscerated like Chile
Chile has a 15 Union participation rate
the United States on the other hand has
an 11 Union participation rate
um which is unimaginable to think about
is unimaginably consider considering
what we've done in Chile uh so I think
that factors into this a lot you talk
about democracy at work you talk about
uh you know how how uh you know
workplaces uh should Implement a
democratic process even though it's
authoritarian
um currently and people expect that and
people think that that's normal
um I I think that that is the main
mechanism of pushback is is uh building
out I want to ask maybe this is why I'm
just wondering why are Americans so
docile
yes
in many ways that's what we've been
talking about even if it hasn't been
explicitly in so many words
and the whole world wonders about it I
wonder about it but I can assure I I go
to Europe fairly often I give talks you
know papers at University conferences
and crap like that
um and that's the question I'm asked
what is it
you know the French have the yellow
vests a few years ago you guys may
remember before the pandemic hit this
amazing uh outpouring of of opposition
among the French people to the rising
cost of gas and electric bills and so so
yeah I mean what is it about the
American people they Grumble uh you know
what they say at the bar at night you've
been there you know what they say over
the dinner table you know they have
feelings about this they you know
they're angry about what the you know
the price of eggs going up the two to
three times over the last six eight
months everybody knows you can't I mean
inflation is a phenomena that pokes you
in the nose you know every day so people
know but they have this sense somehow in
America that it is either impossible or
unwise to get together with other people
enjoy the the the benefit of having
numbers and beginning to actually act
democratically to say that we the people
have a right to be heard to have a right
to shape the policies that we live under
they say it
but they don't really believe it and
somehow in there I think lies the
explanation for this docility for this
hesitance to get out there and and do
stuff it it's
and it's very discouraging and and I
want to go back to the story I told you
about the board of directors I meet with
when you have docility like that you are
encouraging the corporate board of
directors to think that they can get
away with virtually anything Amazon is
in the process in case you didn't hear
it of doing away with the free delivery
you know because it it they they see
profit they're going to start changing
the the they've issued some some
indications
only if you buy so much will you get if
you don't buy that much you don't get it
for free and you might get it sooner
than the other guy's gonna get it later
they're beginning to play the game
because they don't think they have any
opposition they have to fear
part of me I wonder like I imagine if
you were to get like the majority of
people interacting and caring together
about one cause in My Mind imagining
Americans doing that is almost hard to
believe because the
different tribes the two different
tribes here in America are
so opposed and the propaganda on either
side is so
um compelling it's like if you if you
have a bunch of let's say liberals
industry protesting uh inflation and and
price gouging and all this it would be
so easy for Fox News and their saddle
and all their cronies to vilify them in
whatever way they wanted right to
prevent the other half from
participating and I feel like there's no
critical mass eventually where it's like
because you need but you need both
people to come together on a cause to
get anything done I feel like in a
meaningful way to have enough people I
wonder if that's why there are plenty of
issues there are plenty of issues where
the American public actually unite on uh
across the board abortion being one of
the greatest examples of this like the
protection of abortion rights being one
of the best examples of this and yet
obviously uh you know the Democratic
party doesn't do enough to protect that
and the Republican Party very openly uh
Works to undermine it and not even
through the legislative body but through
State legislatures and the court process
in the court system if a conservative
who let's say even supports that
privately they I think they would be
afraid of being perceived as a Trader if
they went out into the streets or
something like that to support the cause
I think I I think that they have uh you
weaponized wedge issues very effectively
in the United States of America uh as a
way to as a mega to divide the working
class the working class has no class
Consciousness in this country
historically they haven't had class
Consciousness in the country even like
in the Eugene Debs era there was still I
mean there were still plenty of people
like the the Steinbeck quote that comes
to mind immediately is about how
socialism will never work in the United
States of America because uh the workers
do not see themselves as an exploded
proletariat but temporarily embarrassed
millionaires
um I I mean that's paraphrased and maybe
falsely attributed to this topic but it
doesn't matter my point is that that
attitude still exists American
exceptionalism is built into people's
minds Americans still believe that false
meritocracy that doesn't exist these are
all these are all uh ideas that the
Bourgeois state and its institutions
have basically reinforced through even
neoliberal institutions like uh where
Professor wolf graduated from Yale all
the way down to you know our regular
education and what people are taught in
schools from you know pre-k through 12.
so that's it there is it's it's very
successful this is what happens when you
have a country that has no class
Consciousness and capitalists of one and
it makes sense we are the labor
aristocracy we are living in the
Imperial core we do benefit from the
global exploitation of the third world
uh the the exploitation of the global
South and we kind of recognize that we
recognize that the cheap goods and
commodities that we consume are are you
know sedating the masses and people are
relatively comfortable that's why no one
[__] Rises up when you see a 700
percent increase in profits for an egg
company the the California egg company
that just reported like like insane
record-shattering profits and and they
did that uh because egg prices were
increased there's so much there's too
much corporate consolidation they have
all the power and just like Professor
wolf pointed out Amazon uh is is doing
that single-handedly monopolizing
e-commerce and then slowly but surely
increasing prices uh and doing whatever
the [__] they can and there's no way to
fight back against it so I don't know if
you have an opinion about that or I it's
probably a whole lot of stuff you know
but it is it is concerning I mean
yeah I mean
I have other I have to get off I have to
other things right right right I did
want to end I did want to end my my part
of this
on a pot on a more positive note because
I I agree with everything you've said I
really do but I I want to again point
out these things can change
France in France it was believed that
their working class was divided beyond
all repair basically divided as follows
a vast group of of people in the middle
then an extreme right wing associated
with the Le Pen family that you may have
heard about uh father and now the
daughter as a leader of a far right wing
anti-immigration thing and then a
fractured left with a Communist Party a
Socialist Party a green party and all
the rest and that they could not get
together the union there are eight
National Union federations in France we
have won the AFL-CIO they have a and
they've never been able to agree on
anything in the last five years all of
that has changed
here's what's happened in the last
election that Mr McCraw won
and that Le Pen
uh came in second
a very very close third one or two
percentage points less was a unified
left
in which the Communist socialists greens
and three or four other parties all got
together
unheard of and they were as I say two
three percentage points less than Mr
macron that's all the division in France
is very dangerous for the government in
power because the left was Unified
in the demonstrations that had involved
millions of people over the last two
weeks and are scheduled to continue next
week again
the eight different trade unions who had
been unable to agree on anything else
are all agreed they are all together
leading this movement it's led by the
labor unions United France has never
seen this before
and I believe it shows the wisdom of a
famous remark made made by a great
leader years ago here's how it goes
for many decades nothing seems to happen
and then in a few weeks decades happen
who said that Professor wolf man's name
the man's name was Vladimir but not
zielinski
um you can think about who it might be
and you'll guess right brilliant guy
he's really good really smart guy I want
us I know you have to go but thank you
so much for calling it was incredible
talking to you you're so so great
maybe you'd be uh open and coming back
again sometime that would be awesome
absolutely I like your program I like
the style and the way you do things oh
thank you and you don't you you don't
beat around the bush which I really
appreciate because I live in a country
where beating around that bush seems to
be coming I only beat one Bush Professor
all right but I do want to say
Peterson's grandmother's Bush I do want
to say um you have a YouTube channel
democracy at work or you're associated
with it and somehow you could subscribe
on YouTube I'm gonna put the link in the
description you guys are gonna be uh
greatly benefited by following uh
Professor wolf on tick tock on YouTube
we'll put all the links in the
description democracy at work on uh
across social media we'll put them all
in there but go please support and
follow This brilliant man who's gonna be
calling in again soon hopefully we're
gonna get Ethan to read State and
Revolution
and then we'll talk about
all right
all right thank you again thank you so
much
he's so smart yeah everything he says is
so insightful and very scary frankly I'm
glad he wrapped up on a positive note
but I don't even think I don't even
think that uh Professor wolf is like
particularly smart uh he is but I think
it's more so I think he will agree I
think he will agree with that man just
called in no I think he'll agree with
what I'm about to say it's common sense
I think this is what a lot of people
failed on and he'd be smart and have
good comments yes but what he is talking
about for the most part especially as it
pertains to uh you know uh uh talking
about some of these issues and and
foreseeing the inevitable is just common
sense it's it's more descriptive really
I think that's what that's the the the
fundamentals of uh any kind of like
marxian analysis I I know what you mean
but God damn he's he's awesome I'd even
get to I had all these questions lined
up about
um
Jordan Peterson I'm gonna get him next
time I really want to hear his analysis
yeah there's so much to talk about about
uh Marxism
but uh he's brilliant though yes I I do
think Richard wolf is great for the
record I'm just just not it just not
that bro no no I I think like the the
the real Brilliance uh of Richard Wolff
comes from being able to describe
complex uh you know
complex texts with uh with ease I was in
a way that is digestible that makes
sense but but ultimately like he is
simply
describing common sense I think everyone
should understand that it's it's
approachable this kind of stuff is
approachable uh
if you just simply think it through
that's what I was really enjoying I mean
everything he was saying I was really um
it was really easy to consume and fall I
mean the guys we gotta get we have to
harvest his brain more I need to steal
more of his labor
did I steal his labor no no that's not
because he's not my employee I think
what I think can I steal his labor how
can I I'd like to steal his labor this
is something people this is something
people in my community say about like
people who I quote unquote steal my
takes or whatever but like agitative
propaganda is important for class
consciousness
and therefore it doesn't matter who's
repeating it as long as other people are
hearing it like I don't give a [__] and
I don't think he would give a [__]
either
having the opportunity to having the
opportunity to describe such uh subjects
to a broader audience of liberals is
always good
hang on one sec that is weird what the
[__]
sorry
um great guy we should reach out let's
get him back on let's schedule it
put 30 seconds after you guys off the
line what nothing I was just no right
and then say despite Hassan thinking
you're not that smart that's not what I
meant I obviously think he's I'm gonna
send that clip in the email everyone's
gonna everyone's gonna [__] yeah
everyone's gonna run with that now I
love Richard wolf I think he's great
when I told you wolf was coming on you
were you said oh [__] yeah
yeah well when you sent it to me Ethan
was like we gotta get this guy on I was
shocked I have so many I have so many
questions I had so many more questions
about how like the distinction between
liberal like you or an anti-capitalist I
wanted to talk to him about AI uh as a
tool for capitalists and and what like
the AI future uh represents for the
labor force
um you know where the marxists are in in
our uh colleges in Academia and what the
most right-wing departments are in
colleges will we have a lot more to talk
about
um and we'll get to that next time we
have him on
yeah I uh
I was very thankful for that so there it
is man the wolf mhm
yeah oh we didn't even ask him a single
Law and Order question which is messed
up yeah as the executive producer of the
longest running uh crime show
what did you think about uh that episode
with Logan Paul yeah why do you why do
you do so much propaganda professor
professor wolf how did you find time in
your busy schedule to write so many
indirect so many episodes what was it
like working with Richard Belzer you
know great actor Munch absolutely we
should hit him with that next time now
that we're friends that'd be cool what
is iced tea like on OG or SVU guys you
think he would you hear us we can't have
been the first ones to make that joke
he's got to know
uh do you think he'll know what's
probably been here for the last 30 years
right
so yeah I'm sure he's he's been hit with
that yeah but it was dope this was a
great opportunity all right but we still
got a lot of news to cover uh do you
want to go through these like these line
items oh I wanted to show you know
that's a good point because I I know you
probably gotta you can't stay too long
yeah how long we got you because I
there's a lot here I gotta leave it at
12 30 as I always do okay cool I just
want to show you this because it's so
funny we can move on to the main stories
but Rudy [__] Giuliani I mean I love
to make fun of this ghoul this man is
the it was the president's uh a lawyer
not that long ago uh yeah here another
clip America's mayor he is America's
mayor as we all know and uh he has this
uh fantastic podcast we've watched a few
excerpts enjoy this one um as he pulls
up a clip
he's high tech he's about to do react
[__] watching this [__] I love that well
let's see of course depression never
ever stay in your [__] Lane oh dude
I've done that
I've done this there's someone behind
you you're laughing but I've done this
in the camera that's just moving it and
zooming in this is [__] awesome it's
not playing it's not playing
and the glare from the light makes the
corner of the screen why is he zooming
and panning it's a sexual dance
I don't even know why he's showing this
clip it didn't end up being really
interesting but they feel and it's so
quiet you can't hear yeah you can't hear
it it's playing I have the volume maxed
out it's playing off the tablet and then
so here I'll just pull back that's it
that was the clip well then and then he
pulled I just yes that's no no that's
his clip that he got it yeah what why
did he pull that it was him talking
about ice cream I didn't understand the
significance he's not even I'm taking a
moment because what I say will be edited
if I don't
oh he's just that upset about it I I
have had issues this man wow is a
powerful this man's coming from our jobs
Ethan I love it he's gonna have that
dentist guy that you have on next week
he's gonna have the dentist guy on to to
interview Donald Trump Jimmy Jimmy would
go on [__] absolutely knowing Jimmy
he's probably already met him too
they're dogs hey I wanna so just to hit
a couple of things at the top Aiden told
you to kill yourself that was cute that
was funny yeah um he also today said to
about trans people my pronouns are kill
them I saw I haven't like seen the full
clip but I think he was what was he he
was looking at like
was a middle school teacher talking
about her her
uh Fringe pronouns that's that's cool
man that's nice that that was he says my
pronouns are kill them he is such a he's
such a little edgy teen like going
through his 4chan phase like but in
front of thousands of people yeah he's
gonna yeah by the way that that hairline
is not looking hot like that thing has
gone back dude hey don't you know don't
go after Ethan you know what I mean
that's what happens to your hairline do
you see that it seems noticeably
every time he drops another Fat rope at
his sister he's like losing another he's
losing another inch of his hairline oh
[__]
he's just like oh I accidentally jerked
off to his sister again [__] so cringe
bro so all you guys I get to pick your
pronouns my pronouns is kill slash them
okay but that's not really funny because
I mean
people are like wanting to kill them
yeah well which is like makes that super
crazy thing to say the weirdest part
about this that I find particularly
fascinating is that like he's saying
this but like is he ideologically
genuinely motivated to like actually
kill trans people I don't think so I
think he and what's really important and
this is not a defensive Aiden Ross in
any way shape or form
this is more so a criticism of the
structure itself that like in
entertainment anti-trans rhetoric is so
popular that even if you're not
transphobic originally or don't give a
[__] or haven't really thought it
through you can lean into that kind of
rhetoric as violently as possible like
he has thus far like he's doing
currently specifically to gain clout and
prominence through uh some of the more
right-wing circles that is what's truly
fascinating about this is that like
someone as stupid as Aiden Ross who
hasn't even been like ideologically
motivated to like be angry at trans
people in the same way that like
fascists like Matt Walsh are uh facts
like Matt Walsh or you know the those
over the daily wire are
um he will still repeat that like a
toddler he's winking to them yeah he
will repeat those talking points like a
[__] toddler with with diminished
brain capacity
so that you know uh he will be welcomed
by this audience well that's don't know
why I think this is a big audience to be
fair his folks are like tater tots so it
makes sense he's pandering to them sorry
but okay as we're uh have about 30
minutes left let's talk about our main
story here Trump finally at long last
week saying Trump's back baby he had his
first campaign rally today and none
other than the great city with the
illustrious and wonderful history Waco
Texas hell yeah baby mm-hmm it's the
we're holding out brother of course uh
is it not a coincidental that uh he held
it there at the infamous uh raid
uh that killed a bunch of people 30th
anniversary 30th anniversary in fact
yeah why would he want to connect his
campaign to the Waco maybe you watch the
new Netflix documentary and was like and
got the wrong idea like he was like the
those guys over at Waco they were good
guys they were very fine people like
obviously the ATF is somehow more
monstrous and horrific than like uh
because the police were the [__] yeah
really [__] that up like let me let me
just point something here okay I'm no
I'm no fan of the three letter agencies
okay and and you know give it up to the
ATF to be the worst guys in a situation
that involved a like pedophile cult
leader yeah yeah yeah like they they
still somehow were like no no no you
don't understand we're the villains of
the story yeah um
Trump's channeling that I love that no
matter it's but that is insane it is
insane to look at that situation and be
like I actually will take a side on this
I'm siding with the pedophile cult
leader that's it that's I was wondering
are you with but also he's Pro police so
I just I I guess I just don't understand
any side of this one but here he is
um French Davidians they got some good
ideas I love the pedophiles I like a
young girl who doesn't other than the
pedophilia stuff like obviously the
Branch Davidians they sold a lot of guns
folks they did they loved their guns
true believe me it's probably why you
know here he is kicking it off let's
take a listen and a look Glory Glory
Hallelujah look it's real America oh yes
sir it's real America they got Uncle Ted
huh I'm telling you the whole world
sucks and America's catching up but here
in Waco Texas with the real [__] kickers
this don't suck at all
what in the [__] this your people hell
yeah we kicking [__] and suck a dirt
down here boy pass me that vinyl
chloride son I mean yeah Ted Nugent is
like a disgusting little piglet so he
loves he loves that like he's like yeah
[Music]
protect Shredder from Ted Nugent
oh Alfredo's here too hey Freddy
they came with uh Gila today
[Music]
hey I'm taking Shredder to the um
another vet after the show today a
specialist yeah
and then I didn't did you know that
there was like internal medicine like
specialist vets I did not know that and
I didn't either that's crazy yeah so
he's we're gonna go see what they have
to say but anyway let's let's continue
on here oh
um
someone grab water for them thank you
hey look Everybody Take a Look take a
good look around you
this is real Texas yes sir
Glory Glory
have a look in real Texas we gotta
fortify the bleachers when he says when
he says [__] kickers he means like that
time when he uh started taking shits in
his own pants specifically so he could
avoid the draft
I think that's what he's called what is
the [__] kicker
like they're just in the in the gunk you
know what I mean The Real Americans that
doesn't seem that seems like an insult
it's as unsophisticated or offish person
from a rural area but he's like but he's
he's like you know
he's reclaiming it okay we the real [__]
cooker around here on his way to the
stage he debuted a new dance move also a
weak [__] crowd size which is sad we
don't like that but it's Waco Texas I
mean
[Applause]
okay new dance moves people maybe this
will make it to Fortnight let's see
the double dick suck is my favorite yeah
we're all doing it he's still doing it
you could see his Mobility he's flexible
so hot God that is desolate there's not
a lot of people there
yo there is not a lot of people there
you could tell he's got it all but he
popped off
yes I love I love the double dick suck
that's my favorite
it's the best it's the best he is the
he's the goat
um is some highlights did you watch the
whole thing or no I I didn't I have
highlights here okay I did you watched
it all how long ago oh [__] yeah I
watched it live dude that's number one
stand dude are you crazy come on now
yeah uh he [__] on DeSantis a lot didn't
get a lot of Applause from the crowd
when he was [__] on to Santa's by
the way which was interesting even in
Waco
um
he he did that he was kind of mid
overall still rehashing the same issues
over and over again and uh most
importantly it didn't make like
mainstream media didn't cover it too
much that's not good so it does kind of
feel like uh you know people are I mean
he's fallen off a little bit we'll see
we'll see what happens this isn't good
because if a lot of people are like he's
gonna kill DeSantis but Trump running
again is the same Trump that ran last
time he's gonna he's not gonna have a
shot people don't want him they've
already said we don't want him he
doesn't have support you don't
understand Ethan I mean it's going to be
a great ride but he seems like a bad
candidate for the Republican party but
but there is no good candidate for the
Republican party as it stands currently
which is the problem because you have
this internal fraction of of people who
want more culture War but they represent
they represent the most viable
constituency again in primaries yeah but
if you lean into that too much once you
make it out of primaries you're going to
get pummeled in the national election
because
the the uh the middle class upper middle
class wealthy suburbanites that
otherwise love like uh reaganite
policies and whatnot aren't super
invested in like consistently talking
about children's genitals and you look
like uh like a pathetic [__] sweaty
crusty weirdo when you're constantly
talking about children's genitals
they're super Twitter brain it's gonna
be great it's I'm just I'm so excited
about it
you also put on a uh a rock show at the
concert I don't know if you caught that
part of it there was a there was a lady
this is uh this is David koresh by the
way
yeah that was I don't know who that is
the Branch Davidian guy that's the guy
oh okay that's the way though guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah I didn't know he shredded
yeah no I love it okay fire so anyway
here here's let's watch some highlights
Port baby bonuses so many people like
that we love the baby baby boom that
will be coming
we need babies all of this is what is
this he's been talking about this a lot
what is the we need babies he he wants
to give like uh subsidies to to yes
families with newborns I think he wants
he's just fearful okay so here's what's
going on in every developed country
there is one consistent principle uh the
more a country develops the wealthier a
nation gets if you implement xenophobic
uh you know nativist policies like
anti-immigration you will always have a
declining birth rate Japan is the
primary example of this a very well
developed economy with a basically
reverse pyramid where um uh you know you
have a massively aging population even
Japan has decided to uh in recent Years
start lowering some of the restrictions
and letting in more people uh and and
start like a nationalization process for
people because they recognize like oh
[__] you know we have no productive uh
we have no productive laborers left if
if this continues
um and I think that is the reason why
he's trying to uh he's trying to get
people to have more children because uh
you know Financial access is a major
major barrier to so we need more babies
we need we need more babies obviously
that won't solve the problem because
like
so not a bad policy you think what not a
bad policy maybe it's not necessarily a
bad policy child tax credits literally
wiped out child poverty in this country
which is why even the likes of Mitt
Romney were advocating for it it's a it
is there is almost bipartisan consensus
on the matter but these a lot of the
a lot gets lost in this conversation
with respect to child rearing Child
Development and how expensive it is but
also how little time the parents have to
do such a thing so without like any kind
of federally protected uh parental leave
uh and without any kind of like Federal
protections uh that would be labor
protections that would hurt the profit
margins of corporations in the United
States of America you're still not going
to see a massive increase in the birth
rate of of American citizens I see we
were babies
record the reason why
uh the reason why America has not had
the same problems that Japan has
experienced is immigration right
immigration has been the main reason why
American labor forces replenished with
younger uh younger people actively
participating
immigrants brother you get the memo
no no no no
greatness for our country again here's
Trump ranting about we must do something
about this ugly architecture people it's
just uh Savage with their favorite part
it will be a Quantum Leap in American
Standards of living we will hold a
competition to build New Freedom cities
throughout our country giving countless
Americans a new shop [__] you
think this is Sim City or some [__]
Freedom City what the [__] we're a
Quantum Leap and living a a quality of
life what the [__] what are you talking
about I mean none of the none of his
initiatives ever end up happening the
only like the most successful
legislative policy for Donald Trump and
his presidency was the tax cuts that we
talked about for the corporations and
the wealthy so uh you know none of the
other initiatives ever actually come to
fruition
Freedom cities people there will be the
freest cities in the world talking about
greatness for our country again what our
objective will be a Quantum Leap and a
promises he's making are like so
outlandish is there not even like
believable I would assume to even the
dumbest people but [__] I don't know in
standards of living we will hold a
competition people will be able to fly
we'll be able to fly people it'll be
fantastic
is
I'll invent a little uh VR machines to
this lifelike VR machines to sleep with
all the lonely men be like real women
everyone for every lonely man in America
no no you can't do that then then the
birth rates will continue to decline
that's like again you'll be able to
reproduce with the machine
that's the Japan problem Hatsune Miku
Hatsune Miku was two sexy folks made the
Japanese into hikamari's that's what
they're calling my friends will be
having Chinese dick sucking factories
everywhere it'll be fantastic we must
avoid the Chinese dick sucking factories
we'll be collecting semen like uh it's
gold he does he does hype up he does
hype up China quite a bit like it's
always like China is destroying us folks
he's they're kidding us now here's what
I will say
Donald Trump is very good at reading the
room so I like to look at if he's so bad
okay well I'll talk about this uh
without you while you're peeing so what
I mean by this is sometimes it's best to
look at the energy behind what he's
actually pushing for or what he's
actually stating what do I mean by this
the last time he ran he routinely talked
about uh you know corporate corruption
and how much the wealthy owned both
parties that was a fundamental truth
that he was able to cut through the
noise with and I think that you know
paid in dividends for him that I think
that that uh boosted him as an outsider
what he's doing now is talk with the
with the future cities or Freedom cities
that he's talking about is
is obviously silly it's never going to
happen but
having said that he must have clearly
seen that there is interest within his
base and within the American population
in general for not only Innovation but
also uh uh you know a new way of
prospering internally uh through
economic development through building
new buildings through building cities
and he's not wrong about that that part
of the statement is true like if he were
to talk about uh building like uh like a
civil civilian engineer Corps or
something like that I mean you would and
then and then uh you know rebuilding
infrastructure and reveal and building
developments all around the country this
would be like a leftist policy all right
um of course it's caked with like
xenophobia he's uh he's saying that like
these Freedom cities are uh going to you
know shut out uh Global competition or
whatever which you know that's a that's
another vehicle to sell this with
um and that uh you know that he's trying
to in his words reopen the frontier
reignite American imagination and give
hundreds of thousands of young people
and other people all hard-working
families a new shot at home ownership
and in fact the American dream so like I
said the principles behind at what he's
advocating for are sound it's just is he
going to actually implement this I don't
think so and and uh even if you were to
implement it uh the the ways in which he
would try to implement this would be
fraudulent in general I think
what's the what's the like City that all
the rich people go run away and build in
um the Ann Rand book
you know what I'm talking about
the libertarian utility yeah the
libertarian Utopia what's their name for
it
I don't know that's what I imagine it
would
is is what he's actually he's not
picturing you know public housing or
something like that
uh
and Rand
uh fictional city oh galts Gulch there
it is okay oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah that that's what he's
picturing he isn't picturing the
projects yeah except we do have an
example of a Libertarian Utopia it was
in New Hampshire and because of their uh
libertarian sentiment it got overtaken
by [__] Bears
wait what yeah there was a book written
about it
yeah there was a New Hampshire town
called Grafton uh Matthew hongold's
hetling wrote a book about it a
Libertarian walks into a bear that's the
name of the book
and this was considered to be by him one
of the boldest social experiments in
modern American history
um and and yeah the the Vox article uh
it goes into detail about this a little
bit but the book is great
um I'm gonna have to read this they
basically yeah they basically didn't
have like an adequate Pest Control any
kind of [__] restrictions or
regulations that you would normally have
to avoid having Bears that's awesome
destroy your town
that's awesome dude it's literally a
Simpsons plot yeah I mean it's like it's
like all manner of libertarianism uh
ultimately whenever you talk to a
Libertarian they basically
are forced to redescribe how a
government should be formed while
simultaneously claiming that like the
government should not exist right but
they'll still when push comes to shove
uh whether you talk about roads or
whether you talk about courts they will
ultimately describe to you the necessity
for such things yeah and then when you
ask them how to fund it you know well
taxes I don't understand the point of it
like I don't know why people even do
that to themselves like why go down the
libertarian road I don't even get the
appeal you it's like you know
I get the appeal it's American
exceptionalism on crack it's like you're
you're an American you're an
individualist this entire country was
built on Manifest Destiny and and you
know the endless Frontier you know
making something of yourself being able
to go out and deliver
people and what is it even libertarian
even then
I mean it was still you know in a lot of
instances it was still government
sponsored but it was very decentralized
ultimately I mean you didn't even have a
[__] singular bank that's why there
were so many different like banknotes
and [__] that's why we needed uh some
form of like a like a treasury or a
central bank the good old days
yeah anyway we need better architecture
brother
Americans
American dream we will build new
monuments to our Great American Heroes
we won't tear them down
yes clean out homeless camps from our
inner cities get rid of ugly buildings
that are hurting I love there's no
there's no um further thought into that
we're just we're gonna get rid of the
homeless we're gonna take them off of
this street I love when he's where they
go or what we do doesn't matter not your
problem to think about I I love like
what's he what does he mean I wonder
when he says like we're gonna get rid of
the ugly buildings like because that is
not like Trump Tower is like a a beacon
of prosperity you know what I mean it's
like tall it's fantastic it's gold it's
gold what do you mean get rid of ugly
buildings that are hurting
those cities and other places I don't
know what what does that mean I'm gonna
what I'm gonna demolish I'm gonna start
demolishing ugly buildings yeah he's
gonna destroy him this is crazy we're
gonna rebuild them they'll be beautiful
this is literally like it's psychotic
it's it's what you see all the the Greek
uh Greek statue profile picture people
on Twitter uh complaining about all the
time it's like we need more columns
that's going to solve all of our
problems all right buildings need
columns again right but he's talking
about going into major cities and
blowing up ugly buildings
that and people are I mean that's his
that's his platform hell yeah
ugly buildings that are hurting they're
hurt
to the Magnificent classical style of
Western
Civilization yes
talking about great like Trump Tower
right yeah
or in New York yeah I think he means
like I mean this is like very American
to just like I mean I don't like
brutalist architecture either but I
think he means like we gotta we gotta
destroy those boxy architecture even
though we don't really have it
all that much but like uh it's it's
basically social housing like it's it's
uh you know Soviet era uh social housing
which by the way uh was profoundly
successful for the record so successful
that even like post-soviet uh countries
have uh significantly higher rates of
home ownership significantly higher
percentages of home ownership that's why
so remember that before we talk about
those ugly houses
ugly nobody wants an ugly house even if
you're a homeless they'd rather live on
the streets
um here he is uh finally going after
DeSantis Congressman Wesley that was a
good speech you guys
but they've been very loyal but I'm
and
when a man comes to me tears in his eyes
he said almost nothing in the polls and
he's fighting somebody that's at 42 and
he's got almost 30 million dollars in
the bank he's at almost nothing he's got
no cash
and I said I can't give you an
endorsement there's no way you can win
you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell you he forwarded a little bit just
a little bit on impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hooks number two meaning
on television because I didn't know him
very well but I saw him so he came and
he really wanted I said you can't win
can you how do you can win sir if you
endorsed me I'll win please please sir
endorse me
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture Congressman Wesley
tears tears in his eyes begging
groveling crawling on the floor it was
pathetic
yeah I mean
um it did the other one where he talked
to Sean Hannity about this was pretty
funny too he's like Abraham Lincoln and
George Washington couldn't even save
DeSantis but I did I love that you know
basically I love how he like the means
are the early uh founding fathers what's
your name and where are you from here's
some great interviews of course from the
rally in Waco uh she says she's a South
African Maga preacher
five cents Trump to her in her dreams
that's [__] terrifying so this is
definitely all good
look amazing what's your name and where
are you from my name is lindian hopley
and I am a South African Mega preacher
no
South Africa now I'm living in America
because God actually told me that
there's a Revival Coming to America
what's your Visa status I don't care
what God told you in your dreams these
people are always over stairs dude
another another South African uh that
was a Visa oversayer Elon Musk right oh
is that right yeah I guess we don't mind
but he was able to pay his way into like
college again so we could like
technically legally be here God told me
no no what is your Visa status God
doesn't work in [__] uh immigration
lady
yeah president Trump was in it so I'm
all about just praying for this country
and seeing God get his full reward
that's amazing where do you live here in
the United States I'm in DFW so we came
down girl said that's amazing
that's her follow-up she says Trump came
to me my dreams I traveled across the
world to commit immigration fraud I mean
her job here legally and I talked to God
and her job quite literally is to talk
to the most mentally unhinged people
like he just goes amazing so you know
yeah exactly she's incredible this is
Ethan that person is the most sane
person she's talked to today
okay fair enough
I came here because God said to kill
Democrats I'm here I'm armed I'm going
on my way to Washington DC amazing we
[__] up one time uh with that Nelson
Mandela demon so we all decided to come
to America I'm here to kill as many
liberals as I can amazing tell me you
think that God would make you gay
I'm trained with all the Texans you know
going crazy all the trucks just honking
and going wild it's so great to see how
many patriots there are and so many
supporters years of just this great
movement fantastic and what is it about
President Trump that you love so much
is she even listening amazing fantastic
you have to you literally have to dull
it out you will become as insane yeah
that that makes sense so she that's why
she just waits till they stop talking
and goes amazing all right to be honest
I just started dreaming about him I am
you know I have a prophetic gift and my
Lord started speaking to me about him
and in my one dream I actually because
I'm totally not political I'm a minister
I travel around the world you had me for
you want to turn your light and don't
hide it underneath a basket so I was a
wild party girl and had an encounter
with no you were I I don't see it
but I loved about this is that I
actually in one of my dreams I sat in
front of prison Chomp and I knew he was
giving me some type of job you know I
was kind of like and I said to I'm the
Lord in my dream I said I don't want to
lose my Ministry for this lady and he
said yeah
partner lady what you're describing is
carbon monoxide poisoning okay you you
did not this is not a real dream that
you had you left fun check your [__]
smoke detectors lady
insane like she it's so awesome they're
just in many ways there is that what is
it go ahead no it's just so awesome that
they're like leaning into their like in
some instances possible schizophrenia
yeah genuinely yeah Texas no other place
yeah right like I wanna I wanna start a
cult uh Donald Trump here in Waco Texas
and that's how we're massive weapons
that's how you get your bonafides like
that's that's like whoever is the most
mentally ill is like the highest ranking
uh cult member in the in the Trump
Universe I love it man here is uh my our
uh we love them the good liars these
guys go out to Trump rallies all the
time yeah well here here's a fantastic
exchange uh always good work by them
which do you think are more dangerous uh
drag shows or guns to children
how many people do you think have been
killed at a drag show
uh
I don't know but the long-term effects
uh right or detrimental right how many
people do you think die every year from
guns I have no idea forty eight thousand
forty eight thousand okay well there's
probably a hundred thousand to buy from
drag okay
[__] owned why did they post this
they got owned what do you mean that
sound that's that's evidence where'd you
get the evidence from I made it up came
to me brother brother came to me in a
dream I heard it at the at the South
African Mega Patriot Priestess show this
was wild they uncovered a um did you
wait this is the same woman the
same woman who who are being like a May
or yeah yeah she did own this guy pretty
[__] I don't think she even meant to
yeah no she accidentally she didn't mean
to she was there to just make the
craziest people look cool RS beat
whatever the [__] right side
broadcasting news yeah dub my favorite
part remember
but they're like they're even Beyond
like Newsmax or oam they're they are
just if there is just like a trump
Network it's this like that's all okay
okay so this is [__] makes this even
more interesting you have to remember
she was here to make him look good and
this man exposed himself for they do
hate Valor theft though that's like a
big cry it's probably the biggest crime
honestly punishable by death so though I
don't think she meant to do this this
man's wearing a trump 45 hat he's gold
let's take a look at what happens
me too what was your MOS I was special
oh I see okay
I flew into places okay where were you
places where
were stationed I uh can't go into detail
okay but this interview
wait there's more just we lost internet
or some [__] oh yeah he flew into this
oh wait no it is over I saw a longer
version
she flew it he flew into this special
place and cut the video I can't talk
about it he cut the feed brother she's
like I'm a marine she's like really
we're doing I can't talk much about that
I love that it's my favorite thing first
of all Valor theft is always is always
good okay it is fun yeah yeah I love
doing it yeah I'm a veteran in the
Korean War it's like funnier if you do
it for like [__] that you clearly are
not old enough to be here's one last
clip and I'll let you go it's on but uh
okay this is a bonus clip Trump explains
that if you don't love your children
you don't have to leave them anything
which is ironic of course I think he's
either follow the dots he's trying to
say something
he's not even I don't even think this is
about Eric or Donald they know they
ain't getting nothing in the [__]
will okay
uh Tiffany as well I think this is more
so about Ivanka
oh he's threatening Ivanka wonderfully
Ivanka we're in line well [__] her
husband's way richer than he is so yo
dude how dare you bring that up way
richer than Trump broke up talk to you
soon that's fighting words
happy and Rich again let me go back and
I made farmers happy and Rich again yes
and they're doing a fantastic job
and you know what
someday it'll become time for them to
leave this beautiful Earth and they'll
be able to leave their Farm without
taxes to their children yes I got rid of
the death tax on farms ridiculous when
you do pass away on the assumption that
you love your children yeah
you can leave it to them and they won't
have to pay time can you pause for a
second but if you don't love your
children I don't want to assume you love
your kids before we even get to the
funny part of this like I hate I
the the death tax or the estate tax uh
eligibility
is so [__] high
do you want to know how many Americans
were impacted by the the uh estate tax
how many during When Donald Trump even
increased the price floor higher
fifteen thousand that's not a lot yeah
wait what is what's this what's the
floor on that uh I believe what did it
go from I think was it 10 million like
it's well you have to have a 10 million
dollar property to be eligible uh it's
presently 12 million for individuals 24
million for America you have to have to
sell a 12 million dollar property like
or 24. Farms yeah the gift and estate
estate tax exemption now is uh 12.92
million dollars or 25.84 million per
married couple yeah that's like super
[__] Rich that's 15 000 Americans
total that's it insane none of those
dumbasses at the [__] Trump rally are
in that they're not Trump himself barely
makes the [__] metric there I just
that's incredible how he spins that all
you good old Americans on your Farms but
it's not him this is not him that that
spins it like that this is every
Republican Trump is just a more
effective interlocutor he's more
effective at communicating this uh and
and basically uh articulating it in a
way that it like it corresponds to the
desires of the average American citizen
who think that they have that kind of
money
that's awesome yeah so that when you do
pass away on the assumption that you
love your children
you can leave it to them and they won't
have to pay tax
but if you don't love your children so
much and there are some people that
don't
and maybe deservedly so it won't matter
because frankly you don't have to leave
them anything thank you very much
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let's say they go back to polite liberal
society and decide to go to the cocktail
parties and say I no longer want to work
with Donald Trump Donald J Trump the
greatest president then you don't bring
them you don't leave them anything folks
he's the best man this is exciting to
see him back and forth this is nice I
thought the content I thought it it
might also just be a matter of him
trying to connect with his audience of
old Boomers whose kids hate them and
don't talk to them anymore back to
American value yeah oh that too for sure
as you know many of you hate your
children and I get it do children have
gone no contact I get it I get it
American values nuclear family and by
nuclear I mean we're blowing it up
thank you yeah all right that's it what
is it what a nice episode
good times good times Professor the wolf
whose info's in the description follow
him hit him up tell him we want you back
on leftovers he was great he was
wonderful permanent third a co-host love
that us and the Wolf yeah I mean I don't
think he'd be done he called the wolf
he's a busy guy but I would love Mom
what could be more important than this
ask dick ass ask Professor Dick Wolf I
thought you said ass and dick is worm no
no no
all right thank you everybody we'll see
y'all tomorrow for Friday it's Friday
baby yes
[Music]
foreign